what's going on guys today i'm going to
explain all seven curse techniques that
have been used by members of the zenin
clan
in jiu jitsu kaizen the zenons are one
of three major bloodlines that hold the
most influence
and as of making this video they've had
more members appear in the series than
any other family
within the clan itself having a powerful
technique is valued above virtually
everything else
as those who have them occupy all the
high positions of power
whereas those without are made to either
be servants or disposable soldiers
women in particular are treated like
garbage regardless of whether they have
a unique ability or not
further emphasizing that the zenons are
just not good people that being said in
this video we're still going to break
down each of their techniques but spoil
the warning ahead as i will be going
into content from the manga to explain
it
if you haven't already then be sure to
hit that sub button if you want to see
more jiu-jitsu guys in content like this
and let me know in the comments what
technique from the clan is your personal
favorite
okay so the first one we're going to
talk about is arguably the most
complicated
and that is projection sorcery this
technique is one that doesn't have a
long history within the xenon family
however it was possessed by nabito who
was the head of the clan and also his
son naoya
at its most basic level it allows a
person to perform 24 unique movements in
the space of a second
which effectively gives them super speed
this is why narbita was known as the
fastest sorcerer besides gojo
but there are a few other rules that
make this power more complex
for starters in their mind the user
divides one second into 24 individual
frames
and from there they need to decide what
movements they want to do once they make
that choice they can begin the technique
but the drawback is they have to follow
through with the motions they chose
as the manga says the predetermined
course can't be adjusted once it's begun
meaning the sorcerer has to complete the
motion even if it's no longer beneficial
now while projection sorcery normally
lasts for a second it's been shown that
with enough curse energy you can
maintain it for multiple seconds in a
row
this allows the person to continuously
build more and more momentum
reaching speeds that surpass the usual
limit of the technique
narya is the perfect example as he kept
activating it back to back during his
fight with maki resulting in him being
so fast that he literally planned to
punch through her
this is in contrast to his fight with
chozo where he only used projection
sorcery in individual bursts
so he never reached anything close to
his top speed the other benefit of this
technique is that while it's being used
anyone touched by the user's palm is
also required to move at 24 frames per
second
for most people that's an impossible
task given that they don't have
projection sorcery
so the end result is that they're frozen
in place for one second instead
those who get frozen always appear to be
stuck inside a frame and that's because
this technique is based off real life
animation
before we move on there are a few other
rules when it comes to projection
sorcery
such as the fact it doesn't allow the
sorcerer to majorly defy the laws of
physics
one example might be that you can't just
teleport from a to b without doing the
necessary motions
and it also doesn't let you do crazy
stuff like phasing through walls
if nao was to try something that insane
then he wouldn't be able to fulfill the
predetermined course of action
and if you can't do that then you end up
frozen in a frame for one second as well
final thing to mention is that when the
user is deciding which 24 movements to
perform
they can't move anywhere that's not
within their field of view the second
technique on this list is known as
construction
and compared to the last one there's a
lot more simple construction enables
maya to use curse energy to create
things out of thin air
although the objects can't be anything
too big or too complex
her go-to option has been to use it to
make bullets which is why she carries a
sick shot revolver to confuse whoever
she's up against
after six bullets have been fired anyone
who doesn't know her technique will
assume she needs to reload
giving her an opening to generate a
surprise seventh bullet to catch them
off guard
this bluff is what she used against
marky during the team battle in season 1
but the freak of nature was still able
to catch the bullet pretty quickly
a downside of construction is that it
requires a ton of crush energy to create
something
so mike could only ever produce one
bullet a day if we compare how she looks
before using her technique and
immediately afterwards the nosebleed
makes it clear this isn't an easy thing
to do
during the series the largest thing we
saw her make was this sword she made for
her sister
while she was already injured by the way
and the consequence of that was just not
great
up next we have the technique of ranta
zenin who was a member of the hay before
his untimely death
for those that don't know the hey is a
unit composed of the highest ranked
sorcerers the family has to offer
meaning he was at least semi-grade one
out of all the characters in the series
i'd say his ability is most similar to
inumaki
in that they're both able to restrict
someone using curse energy
while it's true we don't know the name
of his technique it works by focusing
his eyes on the target
and then a bigger pair of eyes manifest
next to the victim from there his
opponents are restricted
but just like her speech the
effectiveness depends on how powerful
the target is
in order to hold someone in position it
seems like he needs to keep staring at
them
and if the giant pair of eyes takes
damage then his real eyeballs also get
seriously messed up
blaze encourages the fourth technique in
this video and it was utilized by ogi
zenin who is the father to both marquis
and mai
this guy is a strong contender for worst
dad in the series and his hatred for his
children comes from the fact they
prevented him from being head of the
clan
according to ogie he was a better
sorcerer than albito in every way
with the one exception being the quality
of their children whereas nao was
perceived by everyone as a genius
maki couldn't even see curses and mai
didn't have that much cursed energy
compared to the average sorcerer
that's why in the manga he didn't feel
any sadness when trying to kill them
both
and this is where we get to his cursed
technique blazing courage enables the
user to create fire out of cursed energy
and then use that in conjunction with a
weapon
for example in chapter 148 ogi's katana
was sliced in half by maki
but by using this technique he was able
to conjure up flames to replace the part
that was broken
the following chapter he did a similar
thing only that time the flames were
way more intense and seem to be
propelled out of the katana at high
speeds
being a special grade one sorcerer you
would expect that over the years he's
used blazing courage to incinerate
hundreds of curses
which is why he was so confident in
telling maki he could burn her to the
bone
following this we have an ability
possessed by trojaroszenin who was
another member of the hay
and this technique activates when he
makes contact with the ground using
cursed energy he can manipulate the
earth to create an enormous pair of
hands which can then be made to do
anything he wants
chojiro maintains control of the hands
as long as his actual hands are touching
the floor
and like pretty much everyone else in
this video he used it to try and crush
maki like a bug
in my opinion a technique like this that
controls matter in that way
it likely has more applications than
just the big hands but no doubt this is
his preferred use of the ability
moving on we have the curse technique of
junichi zenin who was a special great
one sorcerer skilled in hand-to-hand
combat
the first time we saw this character he
attempted to uppercut naoya so it does
make sense that his special ability is
related to punching as well
this unnamed technique can manifest
several huge fists to support his own
punches
and contrary to what you might think
these fists are actually real initially
i thought they were a symbolic thing to
represent how hard he was punching but
when you look at the aftermath of his
attack there were multiple separate
craters in the ground
this implies that the fists aren't an
illusion or a metaphor of some kind
but instead they are real things
manifested from cursed energy
that makes junichi pretty destructive
overall which i guess it makes sense why
he's ranked so highly
now the final power on this list is by
far the most valuable
and that is the 10 shadows technique
this is the signature ability of the
zening clan that's been passed down for
hundreds of years
but in all that time it's never reached
its full potential users of this
technique can in theory control it to 10
different shikigami
however volume 14 confirmed that
mastering all of them hasn't been done
before
when 10 shadows first awakens in someone
that sorcerer receives a free pair of
demon dogs
but in order to control any new
shikigami they have to be exercised in a
ritual
that ritual can be started at virtually
any time by making the relevant hand
sign
as each sign creates a unique shadow
from which the spirit can emerge
the only rule of the ritual is that the
sorcerer must defeat the shikigami by
themselves
because if anyone else was to help or a
system in any way then the result would
be void so far in the series megumi has
gained control over at least five
spirits besides the demon dogs and he
can summon multiple at the same time or
even combine them using an extension of
his technique
with this extension he was able to
combine these two to create what is
essentially an 11th shikigami
and these flying toads have one
advantage over the others if this hybrid
was completely destroyed
they could still return again in the
future as long as mikumi has control
over the two needed to create it
on the other hand if any of the original
10 are wiped out then usually they won't
be able to come back
upon death their cursed energy is
inherited by the others which is why the
black demon dog was significantly
stronger after a sibling was killed
anyway in the mangrove was revealed that
a previous user of 10 shadows once
fought against someone from the gojo
clan who had the limitless curse
technique and the six eyes
those past sorcerers were each heads of
their respective families meaning
someone of gojo's level of strength
fought against someone who was likely a
stronger version of megumi
the end result was that both of them
died and for shigeru believed there was
only one chikigami that could kill
someone that powerful
the spirit in question is maharaga and
besides having a super long name it is
also the shikigami that no zenin has
been able to exercise
during its fight with sukuna we love
what made it so unbeatable as it
possesses incredible strength incredible
durability
and is able to adapt to literally
anything once the wheel in its head
makes a single turn
any attack that previously worked
against maharaga is now able to be
counted
so the only way to win is to destroy it
with a new attack before it can adjust
an example is how tsukuna initially used
his dismantle attack to slice through
the shikigami
and although it wasn't fate that it was
enough to cause significant damage
a second later the wheel turned and
maharaga had then adapted to all types
of slashing attacks
including the two different kinds that
sukun is able to do from that point
onwards it was able to either deflect
any kind of slash
or if it was unable to do that then it
would still regenerate after the attack
was over
this was proven during chapter 119 as
even after mauraga was relentlessly torn
apart by a new type of slash
it began the process of restoring itself
soon afterwards
on a few occasions fujiguru has
considered using the shigegami to kill
both himself and an enemy he doesn't
think he can beat
but it's crazy that this guy of all
people is the one he used it against
other shikigami he has include max
elephant which was able to produce so
much water from its trunk that it sent
nowatoshi bursting out of building in
season 1.
its massive size can also be used to
crush enemies although this can be
counted depending on what technique the
opponent has
rabbit escape is another shikigami but
as the name suggests it has no offensive
capabilities
and the swarm of rabbits is nearly
always used just to distract people
earlier in the video i briefly mentioned
nue but i should further explain that
besides being able to fly
its wings can deliver an electric shock
to paralyze his opponents
against sukhana this had absolutely zero
effect but naratoshi was unable to move
for a few seconds after being hit with
this
fushiguro can also use its flight for
his own movement and just like the other
shikigami he controls
he can make nue disappear whenever he
needs to moving over to the demon dogs
these guys have their own unique powers
since they can use their sense of smell
for a variety of things including
detecting nearby curses
tracking down certain people or even
tracking certain locations
toad is mainly useful for his long
tongue which most of the time is either
used to target things he wants to either
grab like when he grab nabarro or
potentially if he wants to fling someone
away or just potentially stop a certain
weapon
those can all be used with a long tongue
great serpent's fangs were useful for
biting and restricting the movement of
curses and on top of that the shadows
themselves can be used to store a
variety of weapons
meaning megumi always has options
available to him in any given situation
last thing to mention on 10 shadows is
the domain expansion which is not
something he's been able to complete as
of making this video
what i mean by that is that he's not
been able to finish the barrier that
most domains require
but on the plus side it does still
vastly improve what 10 shadows can do
with this domain he can make duplicate
versions of any shikigami
which is why two versions of nue were
seen to be attacking this cursed spirit
as we know he only has one of these in
normal circumstances so i guess if he
was to ever control maharaga
then he could make duplicate versions of
that as well beyond being able to
multiply the shikigami the most shocking
thing to me about this domain was that
he could make a shadow version of
himself
a power like that is fantastic for
bluffing so at its full potential this
domain i would say ranks in the top
three
with that said thank you for watching
this video on all zen and curse
techniques
and be sure to hit that sub button if
you haven't already until the next one
peace out